in the second half of the 2000s i was an
edgy teenager
and as such i had declared myself an
atheist
i went online in search of atheist
content and surely enough i found it
it was the atheist experience on youtube
a show where christians can call in and
have debates with real atheists
it was fun to listen to and i felt more
validated and smarter
after each episode so naturally i wanted
more and so i came across
this guy right here tj kirk the amazing
atheist
the og youtube skeptic at least for me
and the main gist of his content early
on at least was opposing american
fundamentalist christians
who actually used to be a presence on
youtube back then believe it or not
and by that i mean people producing
content which was solely focused on
christianity
not long after i came across thunderf00t
with his series about creationism
and pat conda one of the best atheist
orators on youtube at the time
and then our skeptic at some point along
with a few others i cannot really recall
anymore
at that time anti-religious content was
the bread and butter of the youtube
skeptosphere
up until around the early 2010s i should
say
where all of their contents pretty much
at the same time started shifting
towards a certain direction
skepticism against christianity started
fading into the background
and i mean no wonder the well wasn't
that deep there was a finite amount of
arguments in favor of christianity and
it wasn't the brightest people making
them so
long story short the youtube
skeptosphere had to look for new content
and guess what they [ __ ] found it the
new targets became feminism and
progressivism
and sometimes islam every single youtube
skeptic i was following started making
video after video after video about
feminism
progressivism weird posts on tumblr that
became the sole focus of their content
and as an edgy teenager i [ __ ] loved
it it was a lot of fun to watch them go
against these
purple hair screeching man-hating
fun-ruining feminist types
and then came this little-known event
called gamergate
which saw these content creators just
catapulted into space in terms of views
entire reactionary channels grew out of
this just by doing anti-feminist
pro-gamergate content
including our friend sargon of akkad
whom i found during that time and so
became a fan of his
however the content these people
produced soon started to shift
we went from haha these dumb feminists
to
our entire existence is now under threat
by these feminists we have swung
too far to the left and now we have to
immediately course correct back towards
the center
they want to end sexual dimorphism they
want to end masculine men and feminine
women
they want to turn us all into these
pudgy non-gender-specific blobs who will
live out their miserable depressed life
because they are forced to act contrary
to their own nature
in this ultra pc hell that we're
constructing
that is flowing out of these sjw
infested universities which are now
basically these
progressive indoctrination centers if
you let them win
you will not see any more hot women or
masculine man they
say it's sexist we know it's normal
what do we do the left has simply flung
too far i mean hey we're classical
liberals we believe in the meritocracy
we believe in color blindness
i guess our only choice now is
conservatism if you are a classical
liberal
a centrist you have to vote for
conservatives to try and drag
the liberal left back towards the center
from this
insanity this is where i was along with
millions of others
without me noticing this anti-feminist
anti-sjw classical liberal content had
managed to implant this
debilitating fear inside me i honestly
felt attacked really
under siege skeptics told me that
feminists think that my masculinity
is toxic what that's not true i'm just a
normal guy
i'm not toxic my god these feminists are
insane
what's this they're now harassing some
kind of old canadian college professor
or something
jesus that's terrible as time went on i
sank deeper and deeper into essentially
dumerism
and consequently i was listening to more
and more sargon of akkad
but something was bugging me about him
something was wrong
the things he said the arguments he made
just
started ringing increasingly hollow he
sounded more and more like those
christians back in the day making the
exact same arguments over and over again
just perhaps dressed up a bit
differently each time
i mean it felt like groundhog day at
that point i still wasn't a leftist
and if you ask me i would have told you
i am a classical liberal but
that bugging feeling was there the exact
same feeling i had back in the day when
i first started doubting christianity
so i took a deep breath went back on
youtube and searched for something like
sargon of akkad debunked or something i
was interested to see if anyone could
stand up against sargon's ideas
and the thing about sargon and people
like him back in the day is that they
absolutely dominated youtube at least in
terms of this whole
ntsjw content and culture war smaller
left-leaning content creators who
opposed these people were absolutely
docpiled
if you made a video against one of them
you could expect tens of thousands of
dislikes
thousands of comments people calling you
all sorts of names sending you death
threats
it was [ __ ] terrible so the
environment itself wasn't really in
favor of any sort of leftist content
however despite of this i did manage to
find two excellent content creators
through that youtube search
agebomberguy and sean they both had
videos debunking sargon of akkad
and they were excellent the two videos i
saw anti-feminism versus facts
and sargon of god can't read suddenly
gave voice to all my misgivings about
sargon
and with that his entire channel and
content just unraveled
and for the first time i saw him for
what he really is
a confused and under-informed british
middle-aged man
just barking into a microphone about the
exact same things for half a decade
through sean and age bomber guy a whole
new world of content opened up for me on
youtube
leftist content mostly and i found that
these feminists i've been hearing so
much about from these shouty men
on youtube were actually not evil they
didn't want to end sexual dimorphism
they didn't want to turn us into these
spudgy sad non-gender-specific blobs
i've learned about toxic masculinity
namely that it doesn't mean that
masculinity itself is toxic
but rather that our current
understanding of it has some elements
that are harmful to men
and that feminists position on toxic
masculinity is actually a pro-male
position
feminists a previously evil and
insidious group of people have become
humanized in my eyes
i no longer hated them just because some
people online told me that they are the
enemy
and with that i was out of the matrix my
fears evaporated
and i actually became more well-balanced
and confident looking back at all the
content i used to watch all the
alt-right type content
it all looks silly in retrospect but i
now also understand much better how
someone can just be stuck in it
the number one factor that keeps people
there being fear
which coincidentally happens to be one
of the main driving forces behind modern
conservatism
no wonder they found each other as the
years went by some of these shouty men
actually broke away from the alt-right
moving towards the center-left but
others including sargon of akkad have
slipped deeper into it
sargon himself became a white
nationalist and now serves as one of the
many entry points for disaffected youth
towards the far right
but thankfully i think i've managed to
avoid that vortex
and now i'd like to help other people do
the same i hope that
as i put out more and more leftist
content people from these alt-right
circles will be able to find me
and hopefully i'll be able to change
their minds just like how my mind was
changed back in the day in light of new
evidence
or maybe i'll just get docpiled or
something who knows
anyway for the time being this far-right
resurgence both on youtube and in real
life seems to have slowed down
so that's good but still the most
important work we have right now i feel
like is to prevent people from going
down the far right vortex
and that's what i'm going to do aside
from making videos dunking on elon
musk's stupid [ __ ] ideas
first off because i really enjoy doing
them and second because those things
pull some serious audiences like holy
[ __ ]
anyway i hope you enjoyed this little
blurb from me and if you like my content
then please consider liking and
subscribing
and i'll see you when i'll see you